foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
new video I want to have a look at the
major update George RR Martin has given
us on his not a Blog website in his new
update he revealed a lot of very
interesting information about House of
the Dragon he also gave his thoughts
about House of the dragon's most recent
episode let's have a look at what he
said because I think most of you will
enjoy this as much as I did so after he
went over what has happened in football
this week he says I had almost forgotten
how good it feels to win so life is
magical and full of joy right now at any
rate how so the dragon has helped
brighten my Sundays as well I mean I
cannot really review the show that would
be crazy I'm hardly objective but I do
want to commend Ryan condo and Miguel
sapochnik in the cast and crew for the
work they've done Sunday's episode The
Lord of the tides was everything I hoped
it should be kudos to Eileen shim the
scriptwriter to Gita Patel the director
to our incredible cast and especially Mr
considine for his job as king viserys
Darien the first of His Name the
character he has created along with the
help of many others working behind the
scenes for the show is so much more
tragic and fully fleshed out than my own
version and Fire and Blood that I'm half
tempted to go back and rip up those
chapters and rewrite the whole history
of his Reign he deserves an Emmy for
this episode alone if he doesn't get one
hey there's no justice now there is
something I want to say I absolutely
agree with what George R Martin has said
right here what he did as viserys in the
last episode was nothing short of
incredible it's easily one of the best
scenes from House of the Dragon for me
now George R Martin goes on to say
meanwhile I am going to give archmaester
gildane a smack for leaving out so much
good stuff no I'm not really going to
rewrite Fire and Blood that was a j and
no I'm not gonna assault archimaster
gildane who does not actually exist I
made him up for those of you who don't
know archmaester gildane is the one who
wrote the history of Fire and Blood this
is a book of imaginary history
chronicling the a Targaryen Kings of
Westeros it provides a context and a
background for everything that happens
in a in a Song of Ice and Fire and it's
not actually written by me it's written
by arch maester gildane of the Citadel
of Old Town who's a a very distinguished
scholar but also a somewhat
idiosyncratic and crotchety old man who
has strong opinions on the historical
figures he's writing about so some of
his views May creep into the text I
don't vouch for its authenticity the
targaryens were people
they were good ones there were bad ones
some of them were mad they were all the
product of uh generations of incest
there's a lot more I would love to blog
about but I do not have the time there's
a website known as the rat that has some
great interviews with Ryan Condell
including one where he spoke about our
supposed rivalry with the Lord of the
Rings series which mostly exists in the
media Ryan says basically the same thing
I said in that interview with the
independent a few months ago nothing
would make me happier than to see both
show succeed I am a fantasy fan after
all and I want more Fantasy on
television and nothing would accomplish
that more than a couple of big hits The
Witcher Shadow and Bone Wheel of Time
and the Sandman a glorious adaptation of
Neil gaiman's groundbreaking series
those are a good start but I want more I
also wanted to address the time jumps in
House of the dragon as well not with any
kind of official statement there's a lot
to be said I do not have the time to say
it now though maybe in my next blog or
the one after or maybe never since I
have some much work to do very briefly
however I think Ryan has handled the
jumps very well and I love love love
both the younger Allison and rhaenyra
and the adult versions of the actresses
as well honestly we have an incredible
cast and I love them all now do I wish
we'd had more time to explore the
relationship of rhaenyra and Sir Harwin
or the marriage of Damon and Lena while
they were in essos or the birth of
various and Sundry children absolutely
now this next thing he says is what a
lot of fans have been wondering he has
now finally made it official George R
Martin also said and yes Allison gave
viserys four children three sons and a
daughter their youngest son Daron is
down in Old Town we just did not have
the time to work him in this season and
everything else we had to skip sure but
there's only so many minutes in an
episode and only so many episodes in a
season when I was a boy shows had 39
episodes a season but unfortunately
cable has shrunk that even further for
instance the sub Sopranos had 13
episodes in each season but just a few
years later Game of Thrones had less
than a dozen if also the dragon had 13
episodes in every season maybe we could
have shown all the things we had to jump
over though that would have had some
fans say that the show was either slow
or that nothing had happened as it is I
am thrilled that we still have 10 hours
every season to tell our story The Lord
of the Rings series only has eight as
you may have noticed alright now here's
where things get very interesting he
said it is going to take four full
seasons of 10 episodes each to do
justice to the dance of the dragons from
start to finish and now we finally have
somewhat of a confirmation George RR
Martin who is the co-creator of House of
the Dragon has now said the show will
have four full seasons with the same
amount of episodes in each season this
is really great news considering some of
us thought there may only be three
seasons altogether now I know a lot of
us would love to see Game of Thrones on
our television for the next 30 Seasons
but you have to remember the dance of
the Dragons only lasted for a few years
they most likely could have finished
House of the Dragon in three seasons if
they really wanted but I am more than
happy that we're getting four full
seasons I also saw a recent interview
where Ryan Condell said House of the
Dragon could go into other stories of
House Targaryen as we all know there was
aegon and his Sister Wives the blackfyre
rebellions bloodraven and so much more
he basically said they can find other
ways to keep the show on the air
hopefully HBO will have another show
Green lit and ready to film before House
of the Dragon is officially over or dare
I say let's hope the wins of winter is
released before that as well now George
R Martin ends his not a Blog by saying
but right now Ryan condle's focus is on
House of the dragon's second season and
mine is on the wins of winter as we
already know I think this is a great
update because now we actually know how
long House of the Dragon will be and we
also know they haven't fully left out
viserys and Allison's youngest son Daron
I was wondering if they were gonna leave
him out of the show but now we at least
know he is alive and in the the South
let's just hope they will find a way to
involve him next season we shall see let
me know what all of you think about
everything down below are you happy
about House of the Dragon getting Four
Seasons or do you think there should be
less as always I want to thank all of
you for watching this video I hope all
of you have a great day I will see you
again very soon in the next one bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]